le pass sanitaires et l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants entrée en
vigueur cette semaine le passeur
décidément pas la mobilisation pour
dénoncer ce mesures prises par le
gouvernement perd mur cela fait dix
semaines que chaque samedi des milliers
de personnes descendent dans la rue pour
protester contre ce qu'elle estime être
au contraire aux libertés individuelles
manifestations dans tout le pays
provence est capital a rien qu'à paris
trois manifestations ont celle sur appel
des vis des jaunes suivi par notre
reporter estelle charge on en retrouve
tout de suite
bonjour installé à leur manifestation
qui touche à sa fin puisque le cortège
est arrivé sur son lieu de dispersion
rue réaumur mais certains ont décidé de
poursuivre la mobilisation
exactement amira et vous allez le voir
sur ces images de didier mulot une
partie du cortège est désormais menacé
dans une petite rue à proximité de la
porte saint denis avec ordre de se
disperser sous peine d'être interpellé
pour délit d'attroupement avant
d'entamer un cortège sauvage les
manifestants ont déambulé dans les rues
de la capitale par an pendant un petit
peu plus de deux heures aux cris de
macron ton pass on n'en veut pas le
retrait du pass sanitaire et à la fin de
l'état d'urgence étaient les principaux
mots d'ordre de cette mobilisation à 2
ce samedi des mesures que c'est chez
gilet jaune considère comme est
liberticide à l'image est d'aniche et de
jean-françois que nous avons croisé un
petit peu plus tôt pour eux il trouve
cette mesure non seulement liberticide
mais aussi illogique je vous propose de
les écouter je suis contre
l'instauration du pass solitaire
je trouve que c'est une mesure policière
qui n'a aucune justification sanitaire
précédemment tout ça ça crée un climat
d'acceptation d'un niveau de contrôle
par des biais diverses qui a un climat
extrêmement
extrêmement inquiétant quoi c'est pas
parce politique on ne peut pas
voyager sans pas sanitaires un avion
dans les tgv mais on présente assez
tranquillement dans le métro
qu'est ce qui lie à son intérêt dans ce
choix politiques et sociales
on paie rentré dans un super marché
bondé mais on peut parler dans une
vidéothèque programme bouquin je me suis
entendu dire qu'entre mabut dans une
bibliothèque où je voulais aller
qu'il fallait que je fasse un test
c'est une question de confiance moi
j'veux pas confiance dans les
épidémiologistes qui prétendent nous
gouverner et qui décide sûrement la tête
ce qui est bon et ce qui est pas bon
pour nous
et au delà des mesures sanitaires avec
lesquels ils ne sont pas d'accord il ya
aussi en toile de fond de cette
mobilisation a les premières
revendications des gilet jaune à savoir
plus de justice sociale et plus de
justice fiscale un dernier mot pour vous
montrer en ce qui se passe actuellement
ici à deux pas de la porte saint denis
voilà vous le voyez les manifestants qui
sont donc en train de quitter les lieux
par petits groupes par petits groupes
pour voilà lors de la dispersion
et merci estelle 1 pour toutes ces
précisions